q - hi quoting some human pilot quintics
are impossible okay so I'm deliberately
choosing a qubit because if you looked
upon a like you don't need any fancy
stuff here to factorize that that's a
quadratic you can deal with that okay
the Pazzi gross this is the polynomial
they give you okay and they want to show
they actually give you for free we
actually know what one of the factors is
can you show you can you prove me prove
to me using the factor theorem that that
is indeed a factor okay so for to see if
we call this P of X okay what's the
number that I want to test out P of what
to show that X minus 1 is a factor
what's the number I'm going to pair with
that if I've got X minus a they want me
to throw X minus 1 well that means a is
1 right so I'm gonna test P of 1 okay
I'm just going to give this crap it's
it's not hard look this is gonna be 1
cubed which is 1 plus 3 lots of 1
squared which is also 1 take away 1 take
away 3 look at my numbers they all just
match up right this one in this take my
1 this 3 is negative 3 Nelda okay
that's all you needed to show now I know
the X minus 1 is a factor now just for
the sake of it even though it's not in
the question usually where this would go
is okay now I want you to factorize this
thing how would you actually factorize
it further so what what you do is just
actually now that we know this is a
factorization I'd like to be go ahead
and do this you can either choose to do
it this way or you can choose to do it
this way
I want you to go ahead do the division
and then off the basis of what we just
found give me the actual factorization
just like I have yeah okay go ahead and
put that ago
you've got it you have it what oh okay
yeah go ahead
yep absolutely
which is exactly what we did here see
that so when I was divided by X plus 1
to find the remainder I put in negative
1 because X plus 1 is really X take away
negative 1 do you see that so that's why
negative 1 is the number that makes them
today ok so once you've got this right
and of course we've found is the
remainder it shouldn't be remainder
because I just showed it was a factor
right
what you can do with this is you can say
all right my original polynomial
therefore I can factorize like this ok
now that's great that's really wonderful
but I actually can go further now
because see that quadratic that we end
up with at the end right that quadratic
I can also factor X right x squared plus
4x plus 3 and one kind of thing
put your quadratic hat back on what pair
of numbers at my after just to factorize
this guy it's gonna be 3 1 right they
add to 4 and they multiply 3 so
therefore I can go one step further I
can say hey this is the factorization
for the right-hand part like that ok
so what I've done is I've taken
something which is like there's no at
this or side I talked about this is a
cubic formula it takes me approximately
the entire whiteboard to write it out
I'm actually not joking go meekly up go
look up the cubic formula just like
there's a quadratic formula it's a
disaster
ok but we just solved what the cubic
formula is meant to do we factorize with
a fairly simple process okay now just to
finish and this will be able I see
anyone will pack up okay I want you to
look at 3d ok we're going to take the
same idea here's the polynomial we just
write this down 2x cubed 3x squared
eighteen X plus eight okay what I'd like
you to do is look at this they say
factorize right and they say P good good
luck they didn't tell you like they did
in the previous question here or what
the fact is are well here is a factor
maybe that gives you a really sort of
like lead in it's like is it me clue
here just like well you know what you've
got the factor theorem do you find the
factor okay he's all I'm gonna ask you
to do if you're in a pair what I want
you to do is I want you to test a pair
of numbers okay I want someone to tell
me this and the other person to tell me
this okay if you're not in a parent you
can choose either it doesn't matter okay
now what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to find a factor I don't know what the
factors are and I don't have a nice neat
way of finding them just off the basis
of this so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna say look if I can find if I can
test it's not that complicated a
calculator can do this for me quite
quickly if I can find one where I get 0
I've got a factor okay so would you do
that I'll give you like use your
calculator it'll be a lot faster
all I want is this number when you put
in one to tell me what again I'm gonna
put in to tell me what I get okay off
you go as a pair get those two numbers
as soon as someone has P of one can they
tell me first person someone appear to
zero okay now what are we done here okay
I'm trying to find a factor the first
place I'm gonna go is one it's the
smallest number and frequently as you
have noticed you'll end up with a factor
that's not because of that's the way
cubic size because math teachers have
designed these questions so that it's
not so difficult for you okay but you'll
notice when I test it out one in this
case uh didn't work out for me right
what does this mean if I divide by X
minus one I'm gonna get a remainder
that's kind of not what I want right ah
but the next number I try and it didn't
take as long right again the calculator
the next time our IQs me zero there's no
remainder if I divide by what X minus
two very good so I'm gonna do this right
I'm gonna do my divisions right X minus
two that's what I'm gonna write down
here my coefficients to three minus
eighteen eight first step right down the
leading coefficient and then are you
ready can we multiply it out yes
multiply and multiply add yeah you came
with that last one multiply add there's
that remainder zero that you were
expecting as soon as you did this right
now what does that mean
that means I can write P of X in a newly
factorized form I've taken out this
factor and the other factor I get from
this is 2x squared plus 7x takeaway oh
okay that's a bit hard but it's doable
right I want a pair numbers that
multiplies to negative 8 and add to 7
let me say it again multiplies to
negative 8 adds to 7 can anyone tell me
what the pair of numbers is
it looks to me like eight and negative
one right because you add eight and
negative one you'll get seven you
multiply eight and negative one you'll
get negative eight
so what do we just say eight and
negative one so I'll go plus 8x minus
negative one X minus ones you remember
me breaking apart that middle term in
order to factorize now I can do this
okay what is this thing going to look
like I can say what can I take out of 2x
squared plus 8x what can I take out of
that 2 and an X as well 2x what do I get
left with when I take that out X plus X
plus 4 because I've taken out a 2 right
and then here what should I take out to
make it match sure there should take out
minus 1 right that'll change both of
these negatives into positives just
quickly finish this and then you can go
okay so now that I've paired things up
I've got X minus 2 hanging out the front
I've got a common factor of X plus 4 for
both of these and what do I get left
with 2x minus 1 now that the whole thing
is pasteurized